[Musica]
[Applauso]
immaginiamo un ragazzo che deve comprare
un regalo di compleanno sta per
comprarne uno quando si rende conto che
se coinvolti altri amici può spendere
meno più sono e meno spenderanno
oppure una scout che deve montare una
tenda
inizia da sola ma si accorge di quanto
tempo richieda e come sarebbe più veloce
in quattro
l'unione fa la forza
e probabilmente in entrambi i casi
porterebbe ad un risultato migliore
con lo stesso principio funziona madre
natura l'ecosistema che ci circonda è
fatto di tanti elementi
interdipendenti per un incredibile
cooperazione alla vita dalla pioggia che
inoltre l'albero che in oltre a sua
volta un erbivoro il quale inoltre poi
un carnivoro
cos'è per me è sinonimo di sostenibilità
me lo sono chiesta e ho capito che
questa idea di collaborazione per me è
il sinonimo di sostenibilità e che il
meglio del rapporto uomo uomo e uomo
natura si ottiene collaborando
quanti oggi parlano di sostenibilità
siamo qui oggi con importanti titoli su
questo tema è anche la stragrande
maggioranza di aziende oggi si sta
trasformando per essere più sostenibile
o almeno così comunicano
eppure il report ipes presentato a
parigi nel 2019 ha stimato che tre
quarti della terra e più della metà del
mare sono stati modificati da l'uomo
scrive che più di un terzo della
superficie terrestre e quasi il 75 per
cento delle risorse d'acqua dolce sono
destinata all'allevamento e
all'agricoltura e che circa un milione
di specie animali e vegetali come non si
era mai visto prima
rischiano l'estinzione
si è stimato poi che ci vorrebbe un
lockdown ogni due anni per riportare i
livelli di co2 ai limiti di sicurezza ma
nell'arco di dieci anni
com'è possibile che la situazione sia
così critica se ogni azienda punta allo
sviluppo sostenibile
magnifiche strategie di sostenibilità
prendono piede eppure il nostro clima
i nostri oceani le nostre foreste
scompaiono
nel 2019 ho analizzato questa
discrepanza in una ricerca riconducendo
la causa a quei business con un
approccio economico della responsabilità
sociale d'impresa
tante aziende oggi si stanno impegnando
veramente per migliorare la condizione
delle persone e del pianeta ma tanti
altri invece troppe integrano la
sostenibilità come strategia di
differenziazione
apprezzando i problemi sociali con
superficialità
potremmo chiamarle o meglio le o chiama
the best in the world al contrario di
quelle best for the world perché
agiscono così per un ritorno immediato
in termini di reputazione visibilità
quantità di prodotti
il tutto con un minor investimento
rispetto a scelte sostenibili
ma che sia veramente la strategia
vincente
no quello che queste aziende non vedono
è che fare business così non solo
danneggia l'ambiente ma anche loro
stesse
nella mia ricerca infatti è emerso che
ciò che crea il risultato migliore
in uno scenario industriale moderno sia
pensate un po che cosa la collaborazione
una collaborazione che diventa
strategica per essere longevi e
profittevoli e si realizza facendo il
bene per sé e per gli altri
immaginiamo due aziende che devono
gestire la stessa risorsa naturale
condivisa una foresta in comune entrambe
possono decidere di pensare solo a sé
disboscando oppure di essere sostenibili
collaborando con l'altra come nella
realtà la strategia di ogni azienda è
segreta e non si sa cosa sceglierà il
proprio compete ogni scelta ha delle
conseguenze cosa succederà
andiamo a vedere la matrice dei
risultati con degli esempi
i numeri sono di esempio però le
proporzioni sono reali
vediamo che se entrambe le aziende
decidono di b di competere disboscando
il danno per entrambe sarà di 9
parliamo di un danno perché
l'insostenibilità danneggio e minaccia
l'ecosistema in cui opera l'azienda
dobbiamo pensarla infatti un po il
contrario di come siamo abituati nel
senso che più i numeri sono alti più sto
inquinando e più negativa è la
situazione
al contrario i numeri piccoli sono
positivi come il ragazzo di prima che
deve fare il regalo di compleanno e se
spende un euro è più vantaggioso che se
ne spende 10
ora infatti che entrambe le aziende
hanno disboscato il danno per loro è
piuttosto alto perché hanno finito quasi
tutti gli alberi
nell'immediato hanno avuto accesso a
tutti quelli che volevano con un picco
di guadagni ma il futuro incerto
questa non è quindi la strategia
vincente
vediamo il secondo scenario il più
attuale
immaginiamo che un'azienda decida di
tagliare solo agli alberi più vecchi ma
anche di piantarne di nuovi per
compensare il suo impatto e preservare
la foresta
arriva però la seconda azienda che
decide di tagliarli tutti senza
piantarne altri
nell'ambito dei beni pubblici questo è
quello che potremmo chiamare un free
riders ovvero colui che beneficia di una
risorsa senza sopportare ad altri il suo
valore
proprio perché a disposizione di tutti
come quando il nostro coinquilino non
pulisce mai casa ma guarda un po
beneficio di una casa pulita grazie agli
sforzi che facciamo solo noi in questo
caso i freerider 3 un enorme beneficio
senza sforzo mentre chi sta mettendo a
disposizione le proprie risorse è
doppiamente danneggiato il danno infatti
è di 10 a 0
anche questa quindi non è la strategia
vincente
anzi dopo un po mi stufo di essere
l'unico a pulire tutta la casa e inizia
a pulire solo la mia stanza la paura di
essere gli unici a essere sostenibili e
che gli altri se ne approfittino
incentiva spesso a pensare solo a se
manca l'ultima situazione
cosa succederebbe entrambe le aziende
collaborassero cosa se entrambe fossero
sostenibili
immaginiamo che entrambe le aziende
decidano di proteggere la risorsa
naturale in pratica tagliano pochi
alberi e ne piantano di nuovi per
bilanciare il loro impatto e preservare
la foresta
nell'immediato questa scelta e costosa
per entrambe con un piccolo beneficio
ma ecco che nel lungo termine entrambe
le aziende potranno godere di una
risorsa migliore di quella iniziale
quella sicurezza di averla sempre a
disposizione
il danno per entrambe sarebbe infatti
solo di uno
consideriamo che la vita media delle
imprese italiane è di 12 anni se
un'azienda davanti una foresta tagliasse
il 20 per cento di alberi dopo solo
cinque interventi la foresta sarebbe
esaurita ma se invece oltre a tagliarli
né piantasse il solo 20 per cento in più
nell'arco di 12 anni la foresta avrebbe
un incremento del
240 per cento
tantissimo
ecco emergere la strategia vincente
il risultato migliore per ogni azienda
si otterrebbe se tutte collaborassero
prendendo scelte sostenibili
poiché non viviamo in una bolla quando
inquiniamo anche se in quel momento il
danno è distante da noi e non lo
percepiamo nel lungo termine ci colpisce
diventando vittime delle nostre stesse
azioni al contrario quando investiamo
nel migliorare il nostro contesto
anche se questo vuol dire migliorare il
contesto dei nostri competitor nel lungo
termine creiamo un vantaggio individuale
non facciamoci allora abbagliare dalla
supremazia di mercato ed al profitto
immediato ma investiamo nel migliorare
ciò che ci circonda
ambiente compreso perché fare il bene
per gli altri vuol dire fare anche il
bene per se stessi come farlo capire
uno strumento può essere la
comunicazione
nel dilemma del prigioniero che richiama
i dilemmi sui beni pubblici ci sono due
prigionieri che nella stessa circostanza
sono portati spontaneamente ad accusarsi
perché non possano parlare e le scelte
sono segrete creando sfiducia nell'altro
mi è piaciuto così tanto questo dilemma
che ha deciso di fare l'esperimento
contrario e ho indagato cosa succede se
lasci comunicare dei competitor nella
gestione di una risorsa naturale
condivisa è emerso che la possibilità di
comunicare
aumentato del 22 per cento
la presa di scelte sostenibili
parlare confrontarsi crea unione fiducia
senso di appartenenza
collaborazione incentivando la
sostenibilità
da tutto questo studio ho sviluppato un
workshop per aziende insieme ad
un'importante multinazionale per aiutare
le aziende ei loro stakeholder a capire
che fare il bene per gli altri vuol dire
fare anche il bene per se stessi
grazie
[Applauso]